what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we might be getting
another movie added to Phase 5 or phase
six coming before Avengers Secret Wars
and that movie is going to be doctor
strange three also there is apparently
going to be a pretty big shift in
Marvel's release schedule with 2025
looking a lot different than what Marvel
Studios has already announced but if
these reports from some insiders are
true 2025 is going to be an amazing year
for Marvel Studios it is also possible
that we might get another Avengers type
film before we get Avengers the King
Dynasty so a lot of really exciting
things to break down in today's video
and of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos now let's first
start off by talking about Doctor
Strange 3 because obviously this is
going to be a very important movie
before Secret Wars comes out in fact we
might even get Doctor Strange 3 before
Avengers Kang Dynasty comes out now
based off of what we've heard so far
about Avengers the Kang Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars Kang Dynasty is
really going to focus on our world our
universe and our Avengers team the new
Avengers featuring characters like Sam
Wilson's Captain America Xiang Chi of
course our friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man who Nobody Knows the identity
of right now and then some new
characters like She-Hulk and perhaps
Miss Marvel we'll have to wait and see
where the MCU takes us with the new
Avengers but then in Avengers Secret
Wars we're actually going to dive into
the Multiverse and the focus won't be on
our Earth and our Avengers team but on
multiple different universes and
multiple different hero groups this will
not only include the Avengers teams from
other universes but of course the
Fantastic Four the X-Men and the
Illuminati wherever they exist in other
universes and the big threat of Secret
Wars is going to be the incursions and
of course Kang conquering all of the
different universes this is where Doctor
Strange 3 comes into play and this is
why it's so important it needs to
further dive into what incursions really
are we briefly jumped into that in
Multiverse of Madness we did see a world
that was destroyed because of an
incursion however we never really saw
one take place and we don't count what
if because that was animated and not
canon at least so far as we know but we
need to see this happen before we get to
these films where the Avengers and all
of the other teams Fight King and fight
for the Multiverse which is why we are
hearing reports today that Marvel
Studios is fast tracking a doctor
strange project Dr Strange 3 to happen
before the King Dynasty comes out this
is coming from the account great phase
who has reported Scoops in the past but
it's also been backed up by other people
like big screen leaks who have great
reputations and the report is simple as
I just stated Marvel Studios once Dr
Strange 3 to happen before the Kang
Dynasty now Marvel Studios actually set
this up in the post-credits scene for
Doctor Strange 2. we were introduced to
CLIA and she said that doctor strange
has already caused an incursion and that
she is going to take him to fix it
fixing an incursion is going to be
pretty critical to Avengers Secret Wars
because we already know incursions are
going to happen universes are going to
collide into each other and it's going
to be up to the Avengers to stop this
from happening and the entire Multiverse
being destroyed and of course to fix
what has already been done so there has
to be groundwork laid so we know really
kind of everything that is happening
eventually in the Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars so no doubt that this is
what the plot for Doctor Strange 3 is
going to be about but on top of getting
Dr Strange 3 this report also states
that we are probably getting a big shift
in Marvel studios's release schedule for
Phase 5 and 6. and sadly it looks like
some projects are being pushed back a
bit including possibly Avenger Secret
Wars but there is some good that comes
with this and it does seem like if they
do change things up we will kind of know
what 2025 and 2026 look like according
to the same report 2025 will now be a
Fantastic Four film armor Wars which has
been moved to a movie and most likely
Spider-Man 4 and
2. now Spider-Man 4 and Xiang Chi 2 we
know they're coming we just don't know
specifically where both movies have
already been confirmed by the studios
and we know that both kind of need to
come out before the King Dynasty and
Secret Wars Spider-Man 4 obviously has
to come out because Spider-Man 3 no way
home left us kind of on a cliffhanger as
far as to if the Avengers now know who
Peter Parker is now we know they know
who Spider-Man is because Doctor Strange
didn't erase the memory of Spider-Man
from people but we need to know how it's
going to work with Spider-Man slash
Peter Parker working with the Avengers
since they really don't know him and
Xiang Chi has major connections to Kang
in fact it's believed that Kang invented
the 10 Rings plus director Destin Daniel
[ __ ] who directed chongqi is also
directing the Kang Dynasty so huge
connections there as far as Direction
and writing are concerned and it
wouldn't surprise me one bit if he came
back to direct shangshi 2 as well now
here's a fun little report that's been
going around about armor Wars one it
could be getting a title change because
according to the same report that we've
been talking about armor Wars will be
sort of a West Coast Avengers movie
apparently in this film Ultron will
return which has been reported on by The
Cosmic circus not too long ago it's
expected to include Vision ironheart
Wonder Man as well as Cape bishop and
possibly Shang Chi so like I mentioned
we could be getting another Avengers
type film before our two big Avengers
films now for 2025 series it looks like
we could be looking at Vision Quest
midnight angels and Moon Knight black
panther 2 introduced us to the midnight
angels and this series is going to be
one of the wakanda series that Ryan
coogler is going to be developing Marvel
Studios a couple of years ago struck a
deal with Ryan coogler to do multiple
wakanda series and this is one of them
now as far as 2026 is concerned this is
when we'll be seeing Doctor Strange 3
the Kang Dynasty and an eternal sequel a
lot of people are really curious about
this eternal Sequel and so am I because
if we are going to have a multiversal
battle you have to imagine that the
celestials are going to be somewhat
involved now as far as a delay with
Avengers Secret Wars is concerned this
report states that Disney is exploring
options of moving Avatar 4 to November
or delay it back a year to give Secret
Wars December of 2026 instead of moving
it back to May of 2027. this would
obviously be ideal for us for the Marvel
fans because we don't want to have to
wait six more months to see Avenger
Secret Wars now 2023's release schedule
seems to be looking the same so don't
worry about that but the series for 2024
seems to be Echo Wonder Man Agatha and
Daredevil it looks like Echo might have
taken a 2024 slot and Agatha coven of
chaos might be coming out in 2023 when
Marvel Studios announced Agatha coven of
chaos the release date said winter
2023-24 so with this shift it could have
taken in the 2023 slot now here's one
final interesting tidbit coming from the
same report about Doctor Strange 3.
according to the report Marvel Studios
wants Scott Derrickson to return to
direct the Third Doctor Strange film
Scott Derrickson directed and wrote
Doctor Strange One and he even wrote a
script for Doctor Strange too he was
supposed to direct the film but parted
ways with Marvel in which then Marvel
Studios got Sam Raimi to direct Doctor
Strange 2. Scott Derrickson originally
wanted Doctor Strange 2 to be Marvel
studios's first horror film and it was
however apparently Scott Derrickson
wanted to be even more horror-esque than
what we got with Multiverse Madness but
since it was still Marvel Kevin foggy
pretty much said hey it can't be a rated
R horror film and sadly due to some
disagreements Scott Derrickson and
Marvel Studios parted ways but doctor
strange and the Multiverse of madness
has many mixed reviews from the fans
from the critics as well perhaps it
wasn't exactly what they wanted it to be
which is why they could want Scott
Derrickson to return now of course these
reports are coming from insiders so take
these with a grain of salt they are not
100 confirmed but this could be what we
are looking at for the next few years of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and if it
does end up being true it looks pretty
awesome but let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
what would you like to see and do you
have any problems with how it could be
leave your comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf